[Music]
you made it weird with pete holmes
what's happening weirdos this is my
conversation with the incredible michael
showalter i have been a fan of mike's
for a very
very long time from the state obviously
from uh from stella from his comedy work
also his work as a director one of my
favorite films of this past year the
eyes of tammy faye baker incredible
incredible movie he's done so many
movies that i am such a huge fan of i
was very very excited to sit here on the
sleepover couch with him and i want to
get it uh get to it as soon as possible
katie what is the it's july 12th
july 12th i do a live stand-up show at
largo here in los angeles uh so whenever
you watch this just go to largo dash
la.com
and you'll find pete holmes living at
largo that is always the highlight of my
month it's my favorite place to do
stand-up we've been having amy schumer
did it recently uh dimitri martin judd
apatow zach galifianakis adam sandler
has come by the show but regardless of
who comes by as a special guest i'm
always there i do about 45 minutes
new material old material mixing it up
it's always always always super super
fun so hope you can be there largo dash
la.com the next one is july 12th and if
you like the show why not try a pete's
pick i'm actually this episode is
brought to us by our friends at apollo
neuro this is my apollo neuro i'm
wearing it right now i'm constantly
wearing it it is a piece of wearable
technology that helps your body recover
from stress it's basically a wearable
hug that sends these almost like uh sub
perceptual vibrations directly into your
nervous system and before you uh tune
out this is not like a mood ring this is
not a crystal it's not woo-woo it's made
by a board certified psychiatrist and a
neurologist they develop this to speak
to the body in the language that the
body understands to help it calm down
the way i explain it to people when i
meet them in real life because people
are always asking me what it is that i
go like if i go like this to you and
establish a rhythm if i'm patting you on
the arm and then i slow it down
you're just gonna calm down and that's
basically what it does it helps or it
helps you energize up like it does the
opposite and gets your heart moving gets
your blood flowing it has so many
incredible settings it's like a wearable
hug worn on your wrist or your ankle
delivers soothing soothing gentle
vibrations that train your nervous
system to recover and rebalance after
stress like i said there's energy and
wake up which i use before i work out
social and open which is a wonderful
setting for parties which usually freak
me out it's nice to have my apollo on
easing me into the situation clear and
focus is when i what i have it on when
i'm doing this podcast it's helped
people get off add medication and really
help them dial into what they're doing
meditation and mindfulness relax and
unwind and this is my favorite sleep and
renew i put it on when i'm falling
asleep and if lila wakes up in the
middle of the night and i have to get up
and i come back to bed i just push these
two buttons it reruns that program and
gently lulls me back to sleep if it did
only one of these things help you
meditate help you fall asleep help you
focus help you ease into a social
situation i would be shouting about it
from the rooftops but it does all of
them it actually trains your nervous
system to cope with stress better over
time the more you use it the better it
works as i said it was developed by a
neuroscientist and a board certified
psychiatrist who've been studying the
impacts of chronic stress for nearly 15
years and apollo's effects on stress
sleep cognitive performance and recovery
have been proven in multiple clinical
trials and real-world studies i get more
feedback about weirdos trying the apollo
neuro than any other uh pete's pick
which is so fun that people are finding
it and it's making their lives better so
show your support of the show you can
get ten percent off by going to
apolloneuro.com
weird that's
a-p-o-n-e-u-r-o dot com slash weird for
ten percent off and show your support of
the show all right everybody hope to see
you at largo this month in the meantime
enjoy my chat with the incredible
michael showalter
get into it hello you know how's this
can i do this
can i do this oh my god it's so good
we're not being filmed are we we are
aren't we we are the first thing if
that's okay the first thing i say to
guests is get comfortable go ahead and
cross your feet on the couch like put
your shoes on the couch i want to do
that you can or you can i
okay it's not because i'm like because
it's it's it's just wouldn't be
comfortable okay yeah well here take
this second pillow oh that's good yeah
and there's actually more pillows behind
you
here's another one
does this air we just started doing it
on the youtubes because uh guess what
you get a lot of views that way that's
how people consume podcasts now
the showalter show showalter
way ahead of it's interesting so they go
they so it's back in it's like back to
that no but it used to be that in the
beginning it was that then it went to
like the radio when it was like adam
corolla and like joe rogan so but it's
like become popularized now that you do
both right
yeah i resisted for a long time but i'm
happy to say it it's not yeah i thought
it would change it
we've been doing a bunch of episodes and
it feels completely the same sure in
fact it feels better because frankly
like sometimes you go like you make like
a face or something i'm like now you
know you don't have to go like i'm
making a pay you know like you don't
have to explain that yeah or it's like
what you can't see right now is that
this person is making a funny very funny
fight like you have to explain there
have been many times where i've said i
wish this was a video podcast but i i
worried that it would ruin the intimacy
because i you know i wanted to feel just
like a chat sure not like press or
whatever sure sure and uh so far it
hasn't been a problem no i remember uh
many many years ago
going on tom green who was literally
like the first person to do the like
diy
oh yeah his basement
it was in his up it was in his house in
the hollywood hills it had a basement
feel
i won't be wrong it had a basement feel
um
and
oh man that was one of the worst
experiences of my whole life really yeah
tell me every every single detail well
they blindfolded me first of all they
met me in some i was in la for
just like
auditioning for pilots or something this
was a long time ago yeah
and um
they blindfolded me i was met
at my hotel or somewhere in the down in
hollywood or wherever i was staying
and um
his like underlings met me um
and uh blindfolded me because i couldn't
know where he lived
as a bit not as a bit
as a bit not as big as i say it was it
was a very like it was very like he was
colonel kurtz and this was apocalypse
now and i was being taken to the to the
like the i you know to the like
to the you know to the king already got
fingered yeah pretty good yeah
um so i was blindfolded and driven to
his house in the hills
not joking
not about a bit not even remotely a bit
and it was like i'm sorry we have to do
this it was very much like sorry this i
know this but even that would could have
been like you know god you know bet i
swear to god it was not a bit
like
you were thinking at the beginning no i
was thinking maybe a bit nope i was
thinking this is weird i feel weird
i don't think i want to do this the
whole thing was weird i was afraid of
tom green
because at this time he was in this kind
of and i'll tell a little bit more of
the story he was in his like
very unpredictable
phase yes
like the bit is i might slap you or bite
you or exactly the joke is that i had
diarrhea on your seat yeah and and then
the the big punchline was very like
gonzo it was very gonzo and i didn't
like that i hate that yeah i'm not a
prank person
even hunter s thompson i'm kind of like
no take it easy
percent right a hundred percent just be
a normal person
just be it just be a normal person when
people are like hey go out and shoot his
tv i'm like i'm his neighbor being like
don't do that it scared us yes it scared
us so bad yes yes
100 percent normal person we're going
for a society here yes
it's not that yeah barely but it's not
that
hard the whole point of a society is
it's sort of hard to stay in the society
but it's nice yeah like people that say
i have no filter it's like you should
have a film
we all build filters yes to not
humiliate embarrass
offend other living loving people yes
it's not that hard oh so you got stupid
shoes sorry i have no filter build one
you [__] idiot
build a filter you think i was born with
a filter
oh sorry i'm a child great grow up so
i agree i first of all i totally agree
um i
uh
so i go to this place my blindfold is
taken off of course i don't know where i
am i know i'm up in the hills somewhere
yeah um no landmarks
none that i don't know what if you're
like i take it off i'm right by the arc
yeah i know yeah yeah
i'm next to pink's see that's a bit he
lives next to pink's hot dog stand that
would make it a bit if i blindfolded you
and took you to pinks yes and you were
like this is this is a landmark it's
pink's it's there's only one of it
um
so
he
it's called pinks right that hot dog
yeah yeah yeah okay on melbourne i
believe so cause there also was like
pink dot is that a thing
is a grocery store that'll bring you
cigarettes yeah pornography and licorice
presumably where phil hoffman is calling
in magnolia he's calling a pink dog ah
yeah yeah i remember pink dad i mean i i
remember
yeah it's like there's one on sunset
yeah yeah sure so um
and then he interviewed me but he was
definitely there was a whole thing going
on there was like all he has this whole
entourage of young men that were like
very
you know he has a real he this is again
this may have been as many as 20 years
ago and he had a huge but but i remember
that it was the first like
diy
interview show made in his basement you
know with like where the all the cameras
were like that you know the like the
just the yeah
you know like video no
and but he had 10 guys working for him
and it had a very
weird vibe very aggro macho male like a
very aggro male vibe well there's
something there's a paradox to tea green
which is that he's like i'm a skinny
dork i'm a skinny dork but as soon as
his his number came in he was like [__]
you an answer like it's sort of not not
necessarily [__] he was a fat boy
it was fatty yeah freddy got fratty
freddy got freddy um
freddy got fratty
um
so he interviews me he has no clue who i
am literally zero re i mean
barely yeah i'm just the guy that's one
of his
lovely underlings the guy that was
apologizing to me about the the
blindfold was very nice yeah and was a
fan yeah and it was like they often are
the people with the blindfold yeah that
work for the
apologizing blind folder was like i'm
really sorry but like i loved wet hot or
something you know and uh it was like
hey tom you should have michael
showalter from wet hot on your show
who's that i don't know but he's great
okay fine bring him on like he didn't
know who i was there's also a level of
hubris to that like drunk with power
prime green by the way t green is
sitting sat right where you are so we're
not sure is he humble now he was
actually incredibly sweet i was nervous
to have him on he was incredibly sweet
and and almost i don't want to say to be
funny i'll say off-puttingly but not
really
earnest oh ernest yeah he was very very
earnest yeah yeah i remember asking him
about big brother
and he was talking about it did he did
he very seriously did does he say i was
crazy and like does he have any like
self-awareness about other news i think
i think he seems to have calmed and he
refers to that as a different time in
his life for sure but anyway the minion
uh books you i mean this is the drunk on
power like i can talk to anybody like if
if all goes well i'll just try you know
what i mean yeah yeah like it's flying
too close to the sun yeah well
you as someone who's sort of
knows what it's like to be on his side
of that microphone of the interview show
yeah yeah so maybe you know what his
psychology is in a way that i i was just
terrified
well you were interviewing me
that was just no but that the show was
working no no tom green when you did his
that would have been this literally was
what was like early 2000s yeah this is
prime green prime green i
[Laughter]
but this is post
mtv and post
drew barrymore yeah so he actually had
sort of already
like
his like movie career was over already
yeah so he was like an underground yeah
he wasn't andre the giant obey sticker
yeah
yes in human form in tall canadian
bearded human form yeah but so he was
more like
he was still a rock star yeah but he
wasn't
a mainstream
um
celebrity at that point he was sort of
on he had this underground yeah thing
that he was doing and it was getting a
lot of attention mo mostly because it
was like oh
you can do your own thing online and it
can be successful that was when that was
absurd yes and that is what was really
sort of notable about him at that time
was that he has he was self-producing
his own talk show and it was making
money it made money yes it seemed to be
i i'm not saying i don't know how but it
was monetized in some way and he was
succeeding which by the way is what
everyone has figured out like there's
this weird
gold we've been doing the show for 10
years so we we not to to virtue signal
i'm just saying we got into it when it
was like just a thing you could do to
help with torture
like get your get more
you didn't even call it content back
then yeah well it's like it's always
like you could get a little bit of money
because they would put like sn ads for
snack snacks.com or snack apps um
do i get can i see what i look like yeah
you want to see your framing i want to
just see how weird how awful i look
because i have i think i look better
than i do can we keep this in in general
just flip the viewfinder around
yeah
i this
oh god is that what that is what i look
like isn't it
you have to live
all right
show walker sado to himself that is what
i look like isn't it i mean that's life
so um all right we can get even more
pillows no it's fine it's totally fine
it is what it is um this for real
no i'm fine i'm comfortable no i am i
swear i really am i believe you it's not
about comfort it's about vanity yeah i
know but for vanity but i don't know
what i look it won't matter because i
still can't see what i look like
right
look here this look at this
look at that
okay this is good that's better fine
okay this is the show man this is a
[__] it's like it's supposed to feel
like a not by design it just ended up
feeling like a sleepover
like two bros in a basement like it's
not supposed to be slick yeah we and we
need some like uh
you know sugared cereal or something
sugar cereal that we dry with with hand
in parentheses with hand
mike i was writing this morning so i'm
all in final draft michael eats sugared
serial parentheses with hand or or like
yeah yeah
uh michael eats triggered serial
comma
and we cut and we caps cut to dot dot
dot yes oh i love it dot
i like getting as rid of as many cut
twos as i can what i'm saying i use cut
twos only when it's like it's a whole
thing it's like new things yeah the new
thing yeah i don't want to interrupt the
scene the joke is like you know as we
and then it's like
you know
you go over there it's open apple six so
you're all the way to the right of this
page
like [__] smash cut too the
good joke is the you you smash cut but
it's not just smash cut it's like
[__] you [__] smash cut it's
like
it's an extra
bajillion
for real open apple six reference
there was open apple
open apple six will take you over to cut
to cut too for sure but now open apple
is control i believe
oh i'm calling okay i think you're on a
2g so well it's always been
i'm going old school and calling it open
that's what i mean
is that weird thing that weird square
thing with the circles on it
the square
i think it's control it's controlling
it's off that little symbol it's either
controller command no that's although
that's simple she's looking
that little symbol is also sometimes
called open apple
well i know because it used to have an
open apple oh did it it has i've always
just i just that little symbol see that
thing on that that little symbol i just
call that open apple well
you're saying there actually used to be
yes some on a 2e 2gs all the early
apples i don't know there was the
outline of an apple that was open apple
and then there was a filled in apple
that was closed down
and we have just dorked out in a heart
like i love it i didn't even know that
i've been right back to computers i've
always just been
that symbol
the the sort of like it almost looks
like a celtic infinity symbol yeah yeah
okay yeah i like it
um so to make a long story short he has
no clue who i am he's being very like
very good at this he took us right back
to the story well i'm like dad i'm like
yeah like when i it's like i need to
finish you have to i
yeah
he
is
is no clue i am he's being pretty
condescending i mean i have no big issue
with him at all but he's being quite
condescending like he really doesn't
care that i'm there yeah um good feeling
i'm very intimidated and genuinely
nervous and sort of unc you know feeling
like nerd like having a little bit of
like i'm tr i'm feeling quite triggered
by the whole thing it feels the recently
blindfolded usually it feels very
dangerous in a kind of like not like i'm
gonna get physically hurt but that like
this isn't a safe environment yeah and
and then there's and then it was his
birthday or something and they had a
an adult film actress
there as his present see as his gift i
don't
and
she
sat next to me and was
being very uh
flirtatious with tom
mm-hmm and the energy in the room got so
crazy and i didn't know where i was
because i had been blindfolded and taken
there and there we don't know how to
leave there was there were drugs being
passed around and about 20 guys and me
and tom and this adult film actress this
is every thing i've i got into comedy to
avoid this situation and i was like
and then they just
went somewhere
like with the cameras rolling that's a
loaded went somewhere they just he was
like hey let's go back into my let me
show you in my office or something and
they like just disappeared him and the
adult
porn person yep and then i was
like sitting there like what's going on
and then the sweet guy that put the
blindfold on me is like i'm sorry i
don't know what you know like i i get it
he's like i know i feel bad this is kind
of weird like this isn't what i told you
this was gonna be kind of thing and i
was like can you drive just drive me
home
and then he just drove me home
pardon the interruption weirdos here's a
word from our delightful sponsors lucy
the nicotine friend
it doesn't say to say that look we're
all adults here and i know some of us
choose to use nicotine to relax focus or
just unwind after a long day lucy is a
modern oral nicotine company that makes
nicotine gum lozenges and pouches for
adults who are looking for the best most
responsible way to consume their
nicotine it's a new year why not start
out by switching to a new nicotine
product that you can feel good about me
personally i sometimes when i'm sitting
at my desk and i'm writing i like to
chew on a little nicotine get it in my
system it is a pneuotropic it helps my
mood and it helps me dial into what i'm
working on i have chewed lucy i think
the flavor is exceptional and that
nicotine kick is dialed in just right so
if you enjoy using nicotine you should
definitely check out lucy's products at
lucy.co that's
lucy.co and use promo code weird at
checkout also i have to read this
disclaimer warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical remember if you're interested
in a better way to use nicotine visit
lucy.co
and be sure to use that promo code
weird
this episode is also brought to us by
our friends at dad grass dead grass
chill out all summer long with dad grass
because it is way too nice outside to be
couch locked they'll mellow you out
while keeping your head clear and ease
away the stress of the day dad grass is
legal organic hemp that relaxes your
body and mellows your mind dad grass cbd
products are made with a hundred percent
organic hemp that's easy to dose and the
effects come on smooth they offer a
variety of products for their token
smokable pre-pre-rolled joints as well
as hemp flour and variety of cbd
tincture drops so enjoy the effects of
cbd while keeping a clear head all dad
grass products are federally legal for
ages 18 and over and it ships right to
your door anywhere in the u.s go to
dadgrass.com
weird to check out their products they
sent us some i smoked one the other day
i was waiting for it to kick on in some
crazy insane way but it wasn't it was
mellow it was de-stressing it put me in
my body it helped me relax it was a nice
and beautiful way to end the day
and it wasn't like the product so many
you know weed things out there this
isn't weed you smoke and they send you
into outer space this is the return of
the casual casual smoke whether you're
looking for a new buzz or a chill way to
enjoy an old favorite dad grass will
leave you in a euphoric mood go to
dadgrass.com
weird to check out their products dad
grass is offering our listeners right
now 20 off your first order when you go
to dadgrass.com weird go to dadgrass.com
weird for 20 off your first order that's
dadgrass.com slash weird dead grass
you mastered my home yeah and then that
was my tom green experience look there
is you had a limit and i like where your
limit was you know maybe modern show
walter would have left earlier
but i'm glad you know what i mean oh
modern showalter the minute that current
like modern day tell me where modern joe
walter would modern day showalter would
just not have gone on it
modern day show walter just would have
not said this is what to brag about like
if you want to get me excited i don't
care what car you drive tell me about
your boundaries
tell me about your self-respect well
like one thing is like i don't i figured
out modern day
i figured out through so much
failing at it that i am not a
i may be a good-ish actor but i'm not
was never going to succeed as an actor
oh interesting and just i auditioned for
i've auditioned for 40 billion jillion
things and never gotten in the only
things i've ever gotten were things that
i wrote like the only jobs i ever got
were when i wrote it like
with a very with a very short like so
many with very few exceptions there's a
few things i've done but like i never
once went into an audition was like i'm
getting this part
y'all they're about to see modern show
walls yeah like but there's so many
people that that's who are successful at
acting that that's what they're thinking
when they go into an audition they're
like i'm gonna go crush this audition
and get the part i've been i've watched
them come in and do that like i've i've
watched people come in and audition and
crush it yeah and they really
believe like you should hire me like and
if you don't it's your loss right and i
never felt that way for me it was like i
l i was like i can't get this over fast
enough and like i saw you know uh
whatever actor who look you know who has
the same kind of hair as me in the in
the
in the waiting room you should hire him
he's great
that's really how i felt i get that i i
understand and i feel i feel the same
way often sometimes i go in and i am the
jerk guy that his coffee just kicked in
and like i'm like socializing in the
waiting room and stuff like i can be
that oh i i do that yeah i do that
i did that i haven't auditioned in years
yeah
but i do that too but it's i'm trying to
get into some sort of flow but yeah go
you do well but when you're but when
you're
i mean i would imagine when you're on
stage doing your material doing stand up
or you know you're like in your
you're fully in your skin yeah
i think
that
good actors real legit actors they're
fully in their skin when they're acting
yeah i know exactly what you mean and i
don't i still don't feel that way yeah i
completely get it now that you're on the
other side of the table and you're
casting things do you like when they
come in and they're kind of like
confident
i don't need any of that stuff i don't
need any sorry no i loved it sorry pete
no i loved it no no no not me oh okay i
can be that way sometimes but i've cast
things as well and no i just want them
to be great in their audition right all
i care about is what the audition looks
but you but but i actually don't love
watching auditions to be honest
well it's brutal you're watching
people's dreams yeah saying no
and so it's like i even watch an
audition you know yeah sort of like this
even when it's on my computer screen
right um
but uh you want them to be good though
you will i'm excited for them to be good
and if like there's the one thing i ever
could have told myself
in my 20s when i was auditioning a lot
was like those people want you to be
good they're rooting for you yeah yeah
they're not they're rooting for you
[__] person they know they want you
to be totally rooting for you and and
and want you to have fun and want you to
feel loose and yeah and and aren't
don't feel the kind of power that you
think that they feel right
they're feeling insecure too yeah well
i'd love to talk to you about that i
forget who said it but the director is
the best actor on set have you heard
that no i i like it because you're
acting like everything's okay
that you're not running out of time and
you are getting what you need and all
that sort of stuff yes so
when you're directing something like the
eyes of tammy faye which is one i told
you when i ran into you the other day i
think one of the best movies
certainly of the year but i'm like one
of the best movies just like i think
it's so much [__] incredible that's
so that's so nice i really mean it and
when you were doing it i'd love to hear
a little bit more of that nuance you're
not like
uh the action with a cigar
you're probably going like
god i hope you're probably tell me what
you're doing looking at the script
cutting lines wondering if it's right
wondering if you should nudge or
whatever
well you mean like so there's so many
different phases to it because there's
you know there's
the months leading up to when you're
shooting where you're you know actors
you know
jessica chastain and andrew garfield who
are the leads in that movie who
uh jessica chastain and andrew garfield
jessica justine won an oscar for her
role which you didn't even know i didn't
know when i saw you you were like have
they had that yet has that happened i
was like hahaha he's joking like because
i was like remember when will smith
slapped
uh
chris rock and it was all anyone talked
about and you're like
what was your were you like oh yeah yeah
no sorry is this this is like really for
both is it will smith no
that's my wife um can i get it
that's not like a weird
i'm having sex with your wife joke that
was just like what if i got it
she would be very like your face was
like no one thought it was uh i'm having
sex with your wife joking
you said it that's what i saw in your
face yesterday
yeah it was good yeah yeah i saw you do
it and then i regretted it but here we
are no i don't think you should regret
it i liked it okay i appreciate it i
feel now i feel this is a safe space
that's what i'm trying to say um we maya
rudolph did it two days ago we said jizz
like 75 times and for some reason i was
just so proud jesus is empowered just a
funny word i completely agree i'm trying
to get it started like this ready uh
tell me those are new shoes these are
new shoes jizz
i just think that's how we should be
saying it and that means like they're
awesome they're awesome uh-huh jizz your
shoes are jizz
or just or just jizz and she was also
maya was wearing hoka or hookah oh yeah
hoka and she was like once you're over a
certain age you only wear hookahs
i'm sorry to out you they're jizz but
they're [__]
these hokas are madges those are mad
jizz yeah they're super jizz they're
super jizz and when uh we we sometimes
get in the hot tub and go fbj full body
jizz
these are the only types of
relationships i want to have fbj oh that
was an fbg not to be not to be confused
with pb and j or a for [__] or lbj or
foreign yes
i got a [__] but they looked for
longer
yeah
poor poor
poor
yeah poor lorne poor lauren but i didn't
want to
poor lauren poor lawrence the numbers
and snl are down poor lauren poor lauren
poor lauren looks for lauren did you
ever work on snl or write on snl or
be a performer on that i would go into
30 rock which is very intimidating do
you remember being a young person yeah
auditioning again once again auditioning
for sitcoms on like the
some floor up there oh really yeah yeah
it's like going into a
pharaoh's
mansion or something it's golden and
marble oh which part the whole thing
just the lobby i've never got
interesting i've never really gone up
later i went up
when i was not performing just i would
drop off a deal to go well you you must
have been on been on you must have been
on fallon
i did the talk shows yeah i did fail and
i've watched snl but you auditioned and
wouldn't get it
i never auditioned for snl really no i
never auditioned for snl um it's really
interesting that you don't think of
yourself as an actor because that's
that's what i know you're i don't think
of myself as an actor because i want
it's a
i
for for what i said which is i don't
feel like an actor
i don't feel
what i think an actor should feel like
which is in control
and and
and happy
you know doing it yeah is that what you
saw your leads and tammy faye doing it
breathing yeah it's living
when when you're
at that level when you're a great actor
and it doesn't you don't have to be that
kind of actor you could be
a comic actor you can there's there's
any you could be a soap opera actor it
doesn't matter yeah but it's that
feeling that like i'm i'm me right now
and when i'm directing and this feels
sort of like goofy to even say but i
feel that way i feel like completely in
my own skin i feel very confident in
i don't feel the need to pop pose or
posture or anything i
am more than happy to say if i don't
know uh
what something is could you you know the
ad or someone will say like oh we need a
something or other
thing and i'm like what's that what do
you think about yeah i don't need to
know it all i don't need i just but i do
feel like there's something that i have
to offer and it's unique
and
um really felt that way as an actor yeah
i love that i love i'm just happy for
you just as a human person because
finding those spots where you're fully
yourself huge relationships where you're
full of yourself jobs where you're fully
everything it's it's literally
authenticity yes authenticity and is
that what andrew and jessica you saw
them i have to imagine so they just um
they're different they have both of them
have a different process they're both
very very well researched so they both
do an incredible amount of reading and
research and and they think a lot about
their characters and they talk to people
that knew i mean they all that stuff i
mean they treat it
you know
they have they they they take it they
they
approach it with such such
professionalism
and um hard work
um
so
i sort of see it as it as they're
they're creating something they're
creating they're putting a character
together piece by piece the way a bird
would build a nest or something like
that and i'm there to kind of help them
in whatever way i can but also to like
get to kind of figure them out get on
their page that's a lot of of with me
what what if i have a directing style or
or
process it's like to try to get on the
actor's page and every actor's different
so i may meet them where they are yeah
but so it'll be like i'm doing one thing
with jessica and doing a different thing
with andrew and what would that a
different thing with vincent d'onofrio i
don't know don't mention just the leads
that's fun working with working with an
actor you know like oh who are you
working today oh vincent afria oh okay
sure no big deal um they're all
different they all have different and
you're trying to get get on their page
yeah and figure out what what what that
what that's going to be and then um can
you remember the difference if andrew is
interested in andrew andrew is very
i don't want to say this and be wrong
but he's somewhat of a method actor
so he's
kind of in character even when he's not
on camera that must have been he's sort
of has his character with him in a way
so it's not like
you know i used to think method actor
you hear that they're always in
character that literally like if you go
up to them and ask them a question
they'll use the voice of the character
or they'll be like what what do you mean
yeah yeah i don't understand yeah yeah
no for the next shot shot
is this the hallelujah show
no we're shooting a movie a documentary
okay we can't do this every time um
it's not that it's more that they don't
drop the character's feelings when
they're not shooting so if the
character's angry
and you if the character is angry or
hurt in some way
or happy even
the actor i my my sense of it is and i
didn't talk to him about this a lot but
my sense of it is he holds on to that
your spidey sense my spidey sense of it
because i didn't want to be like what
are you doing right now
you know like what are you doing right
now what are you thinking it was more
just my vibe checking it out is he'll
keep he'll keep the feeling very alive
he'll keep that fire burning yeah yeah
um
whereas jessica
is more turning it on and off
i see
which is what i certainly do yes and so
before i do a scene i often my co-stars
on the thing i just did would laugh at
me they'd be like all right we're ready
to go and i would just say out loud i'm
angry and then
i know it's stupid yeah but i even think
robert de niro oh that's more of a
method guy i guess but like a lot of
actors even if they're not saying i'm
angry they are going like remember
you're you're in a fight you just left
that fight sure or you're disappointed i
mean sometimes in your script it's a lot
of actors they just keep a note keep
notes that say like this is what my
character's thinking in this scene well
i wish i had done that because i was
watching what we shot and i i noticed i
was like oh i should have been keeping
like a
like you're more mad than you were in
the last because you're shooting out of
order and stuff right it's like this
should be your six like you're really
pissed but it was the first thing we
shot so i can tell i'm just kind of like
happy to be on set yeah you know like
that's what um sally field did i did a
movie with with me with sally field and
she we shot it out of order and it's
called hello my name is doris i hope
everyone goes and checks it out on
netflix right now um
she made it i
yeah i didn't want you to think i was
being a dick if you watch this later
i always do edit that out edit that out
edit that out no uh yeah it's a
wonderful film i i didn't know it was on
netflix it's on netflix that's great it
just came on netflix great yeah it just
came on netflix great um
and uh she would do it did you say
netflix.com
yeah yeah um
she would do yes she sort of made a
chart so she could look at her script at
any moment and her chart could kind of
tell her
where her character needed to be i love
that so that she could almost just like
yeah like reference a piece of paper
that could tell her where where she
needed to get to because so
she had the whole performance kind of
charted out on paper so that she could
just reference the level and are you
doing because i've had directors that do
that and don't do that some of my
favorite directors really no
it's really helpful i know you do
whatever you do but i should the ones
that make it really easy let's say go
like hey don't forget the scene before
this oh yeah i do that yeah okay i do
that but i don't i don't i don't i do
that but i do that
in the moment so it's like i'll turn to
oh i i absolutely do that but i don't
have it all written down yeah that's all
i meant okay yeah i just don't have it
all written down well i absolutely do
that that it was super helpful don't
edit that out i do that i do that i
swear to god i do that i believe of
course but well but i'm in awe of a i'm
i'm in awe of directors like
wes anderson or the guy that did um
ho i think his name is
who did um
parasite i'm in awe of directors who it
appears to me
are
you could if the camera was on me you'd
see my face i was smiling and it started
to fade realizing i had made fun of a
name yeah i thought you were trying to
think of the name of a movie no and then
i was like oh no you can't get that out
you maybe you do want to edit that out
well i think it was because it was
earnest i didn't know his name so you
just had like a real moment of me like
but if you go to me on on my shop
you could see me go you just heard her
what you heard
when you went
to the academy award-winning director
and i was like
like yeah i couldn't do it in a million
years let me it was like this mic it was
like there were like fog heads and you
went home
like that that was too much it was so
stunning your vertebrae started connect
started like getting fusing together
and i i felt my eye move
so subtle like that little flutter it
was a flower flutter in the corner of
the eye
like if we could have done an extreme
close-up if we could have gotten an
extreme close-up we'd have seen a little
twitch happening you would have been in
video village going like god damn it
yeah that's beautiful we got that that's
beautiful because what i felt this is
that we got that right we were recording
right he's got actually he's telling me
we're doing the recording that's the
sort of stuff and then i say circle that
circle back circle that circle yeah and
those are the types of things that i
can't yet will i can't will something so
small well or or just be so
or just be so like
in it that it comes out that you're not
even thinking you trust
you trust that whatever comes out of you
is going to be that good yeah yeah yeah
so
bong ho and wes anderson and many others
who
you know who i get the feeling that they
plan their movies within an inch of
their lives their movies are like
blueprinted yes so
to the to the to the letter with with
music and the shot and how that's all
going to cut together it i'm in awe of
that because to me
what i doing
you know doing even the the stuff i've
done it feels like
just making anything is like so
miraculous forget making
perfectly them to make a movie like
precisely it
isaac tammy fan the amount of of like
pieces that need to come together and
the amount of like
x factors that go into it to say nothing
of just like
anything like the script and the actors
in the production of it and you're
trying to make your day and the budget
and there's so many different important
people that who are doing their jobs the
best they can and then to think like
to be one guy getting 200 people to do
it exactly the way you want it
and to even have a vision of exactly the
way you want it because that's the other
part it's like i'm shooting i'm like i
don't know i'm not really sure how this
is going to go you know
i'm just in whole foods getting
attractive looking
ingredients and then i'm and then we're
going to go and we're going to go cook
it but we don't know exactly how we're
going to cook it but isn't it okay
that's how jet is and that is how it is
paul thomas anderson is i didn't know
that that was how paul's honestly it
certainly seems that way
uh i already told the story but i i was
talking to him about the ma about the
master and joaquin jerking on the beach
you know you mentioned
i was like oh and that mirrors when phil
hoffman gets set up and he said he said
we were just shooting joaquin he was
just doing whatever he wants to which i
said
i i corrected him i was like but it's
framed perfectly that you can't see his
dick how did you frame that like how
long was he jerking off that you're like
a little bit i'm seeing that he's just
doing this it's like a little bit it
makes me really happy that he has that
that's why i was happy
because
because i'm so in awe of him and he
seems like
it just seems so
like i said it's so hard to not not it's
it's not hard in the way of like i want
you to feel bad sorry for me yes yes um
it's but it's just you know it's so many
people involved right there's so much
going on to do it it's simultaneously a
control freak's dream yeah because you
can be like shave that mustache
or literally like there's two wicker
baskets which one do you want and it's
like i want that one or like neither
neither i need neither show me four more
wicker baskets he said neither it's like
buzzing i need to see four more wicker
baskets by tomorrow
pardon the interruption folks this
episode is brought to us by our friends
at lollipop lollipop is a new kind of
healthier wonderful flavorful fun
soda-like drink
i say soda-like because it's not fair to
call it soda soda usually means it has
30 to 40 grams of sugar and it is
horrible for you but lollipop is a new
kind of soda it tastes just like the
soda i grew up with but unlike those
that are full of sugar corn syrup and
artificial ingredients like aspartame
lollipop is made with natural
ingredients that are actually good for
you it's the fastest growing functional
beverage brand in america they have
amazing nostalgic flavors like vintage
cola classic root beer which is my
current favorite incredibly smooth
wonderful orange squeeze cherry vanilla
strawberry vanilla and their newest
flavor classic grape these flavors take
me right back to a pizza party when i'm
12 years old but without the horrible
sugar without the tons and tons of sugar
they have about two to five grams of
sugar from natural sources that means no
added sugar tip for example their
vintage cola has just two grams of sugar
compare that to coca-cola which has 39.
whenever i read this i can't believe it
39 grams as opposed to 2 grams in a
lollipop their orange squeeze also has 5
grams compared that to orange fanta
which has 44 grams of sugar but for real
for real i'm not just saying this we
always have cases of this in the house
we give it to our guests we drink it
ourselves everybody talks about how
amazing it tastes i really don't know
how they do it it's non-gmo vegan paleo
and keto friendly with less than eight
grams of net carbs per can they're so
confident that you will love their
product they offer a 100 money-back
guarantee for orders placed through
their website
and i worked out a special deal for
weirdos received 20 off plus free
shipping on your order i recommend
trying the variety pack that way you get
to try all of the delicious flavors go
to drink ollie pop dot com slash weird
or use code weird at checkout to claim
this deal that's
d-r-i-n-k-o-l-i p-o-p dot com slash
weird lollipop can also be found in over
6 000 stores across the country
including kroger whole foods sprouts and
wegmans thank you lollipop for showing
your support of this podcast
somebody told me that story on i mean
the best is when you have the prop
person the dear lovely props people and
they're showing you three different
backpacks and it's like they're all
north face backpacks and one's like
green and one's dark green and one's
dark blue it's transport and one's
jansport
in all seriousness
most of them are transported
i said north face but honestly most of
them are jams for yeah you want to just
i got the i got the proportions wrong
three of them are jansport one of them
is it's like an article one of them is
what's
[Music]
but this is
so it's a control freak stream but it's
also like you have to at a certain point
surrender well and and the thing you
can't control everything yeah well and
that's the beauty of it it's very
collaborative yeah now
the the
in the old days for many many many
billions of years movies there wasn't
the whole auteur thing and i'm not gonna
act like i know what i'm talking about
because i really don't i have some
thoughts about it but the whole the
studio director
was
one
important person on the set
of many important people on the set
um
it means the director was called the
studio director
just just just that in the studio when
back in the back in the up until the 70s
really
the director was just an important
person
who was help who was directing the movie
but there was the writer was important
the production designer was important
the editor was very important the
producers were very important the actors
were very everyone was very important
and they were all just churning out
movies
and some of the movies were better than
others but it was a system it was stu it
was uh and then orson welles shows up
and it's like oh you can be a director
of people well more like and then
chimino and and and the 70s it was
really the 70s directors that
that invent i mean yes orson welles sure
but it feels like the kind of current
day idea of
the auteur which is really what we all
are everyone's very infatuated yeah yeah
direct many directors are infatuated by
the idea that being a director means
being that control freak that that's
what being a director is right is being
that
but then but it's not paul thomas
anderson i think is more hosting a party
like which is great which is i am so
happy to hear that again he always says
the work is in the writing well and
richard is like that i've heard this
about rick richard lingard which is
actually shooting a link later a movie
that's how casually he is right now he
doesn't even know what he's filming film
this yes yes
but that but that like um
you know
you just want everybody to bring their
to do their best work you're just trying
to get as all as many talented people
together
and to somehow convince everybody and
enable and empower everybody to do their
very best work but isn't there sorry and
then there are some people who think
it's their job is to micromanage
everybody and that it's all on them and
that literally in the editing room i'm
gonna like hold the knobs i'm gonna put
my hand on the editor's hand and turn
the knobs for him like that that
that not i'm not saying that that's what
what sanderson does even remotely but
that's i do think a little bit of a
misunderstanding about um what the role
of the of the director is is it's
collaboration there's 50 zillion people
involved you're just one person right
yeah you can be the host of the party
and yeah that is to the party when
you're setting a tone you're setting a
tone setting a good vibe and isn't the
movie well you tell me what you think
i've always thought of it like it's a
dream
and at a certain point like you're gonna
let's put it this way if i read 50 books
about nietzsche and then i do stand up
then i just write stand up but i'm not
even thinking about nietzsche some of
that is just going to be in there like
my unconscious is going to throw it in
there similarly i think paul thomas
anderson and the like know their theme
is that what this whole thing you mean
you're talking about paul thomas do you
mind
maya didn't mind
well
um
let's get michael showalter on the show
and let's just talk the whole time about
how amazing paul thomas said you loved
him i'm trying to i could have said link
letter no go to paul thompson has as has
uh link later done the show no okay
would love it okay i just think no i'm
being complete
joking i of course i just know that
there's a moment where freddie quell is
trying to steal something from the rich
woman's house and it's a woman it's a
marble woman he tries to put it in his
pocket it doesn't fit and and all us
film geeks go like isn't that perfect
freddy can't find love he literally
can't fit a woman into his life like she
won't of course get in the pocket i i
don't know but i'm pretty sure if you
ask paul thomas anderson did you get did
you ask props for a woman
slightly too big to fit in his pocket
he'd be like what the [__] are you
talking about i really feel that yeah do
you relate are you just like let's just
make sure we're pointed in the right
direction 100 tell me about it 100 i
just um i just want to tell the story i
literally am just interested in telling
the story and having it feel a certain
way and
and achieve a certain
sort of
level of feeling real or something like
that like my what i'm going for in the
moment is literally just something that
feels real and by real i don't mean
actually real i just mean
like yeah we got that
yeah you know that there's nothing artif
there's no artifice here that that that
it just felt
like
it had multi was multi-dimensional like
i'm very much just trying to achieve
just some kind of like physical sense of
like that felt good let's move on i see
like a music yeah music there's a
musical or improv it's funny or
improvisation like i i i'm i'm and when
you say a dream that actually is a lot
of times what it feels like for me which
is
uh we're in a bubble it's a safe bubble
the way we are we're riffing we're kind
of in it
this is a tone our brain is kind of like
operating on a different level right now
where we're just kind of in this bubble
yes so i try to keep everything in the
bubble we're in the bubble we're playing
we're we're we're
safe we're safe we're emotional
we're we're we're p we're we're open
we're very open we're we're open we're
raw we're
this is important
this has value
this in and of itself in and of itself
nothing's off limits yes take a chance
take a risk your feelings matter your
support your opinion matters yes and if
you make a joke and i say bong hit
you will join me in whatever soup i'm
standing in yes yes you'll go look i see
what happened yes and now you're
embarrassed yes but that's what art is
yes yes and so commercial and so you're
a little buzzed everyone's got a little
buzz going off of that yeah and so
inside that little buzz
we're not we're safe and we're trying to
make something great because what the
hell else are we doing here if we're not
doing that i was just talking to
somebody though my buddy uh and we were
saying how actually rare it is that
people go
let's make something great yeah it's
actually that's that's one of the
reasons i think and that's so fun
watching what a great director you are
but like that's what yeah that's what we
were doing on wet hot dogs we were doing
it it's always like let's
this is cool that we have this
opportunity to do this let's make
something great let's try to make
something great yeah let's try to make
it special let's try to make it count i
think it counts i think it's special
yeah and so
there's just that it's love it's love
it's love i also would add to that i
think it's owning
i'm all about in and of itself right now
so the shoot the day the scene
the page
should be a reward of itself like
something like like in the 60s we're
figuring it out man like we're doing a
scene but we're present and we're alive
and i'm helping you come alive you're
helping me come alive the crew is coming
along what a gift what a gift we get to
do this for right we get to do this and
and and and
and and let's make it count let's have
fun but wouldn't would you agree that
the first step is saying almost
declaring we're gonna make something
great or
acknowledging the opportunity the
potential of making something great i
think that's the first step to making
something great sure sure some people
are like i think have you ever had
someone sell it say this i think we
could sell this like that is just a
boner killer right
like mike i think nobody owns the rights
to good night
moon like we're thinking we're thinking
who plays the moon we could get like a
great moon yeah
well
there's look i'd be lying if i didn't
say there's a part of me that i mean i
i know what you mean
i you know what you know what i'll say i
wish i could do that
the i bet we could sell yeah moon
i wish that i had
the ability to
like
not need it
as crazy as this is gonna sound i this i
really sometimes i don't i love what i
do i don't want to be doing anything
else but there are some times i could
look in my past and say i wish i'd
cared less almost
it's really cool
i love it so then i could just like make
some money sometimes and like
and not have it be so you know precious
precious and and um i've gotten that
like i can't i can't do this i can't do
this you know or you know and i've
gotten better i've gotten way better at
that i've done
plenty of things over the last you know
10 or 15 years where i did let go of
that part of me that like any little
part of it that wasn't perfect and i
could you know or whatever that it's
okay to do something for the money right
it's okay to
it's okay to like need to make money and
do something that you don't that that
you don't think is perfect
because you as long as no one's getting
hurt
you know as long as basically moral yeah
yeah like as long as as as you can like
go to sleep at night go go ahead go make
some money well you and i have uh i
still have residual east village street
cred you know what i'm saying like yeah
i have the belief well but you were the
um darling you can say darling well that
for sure but but no but you were
no but you were doing the um e-trade
baby
yeah that was later and you know what
dude and that and i would you know baby
well but that's a perfect example of
like you must have done very nicely
you must have done very nicely as the
e-trade baby yes and that's a great
thing you were like
you know
having fun and that was the kind of
thing that i probably would have like
not gone out for i would have gone out
for it but i wouldn't have gotten it i
mean i probably auditioned for it
actually i probably even almost everyone
in new york did but anyway what were you
gonna say this is very virtue signally
but i think it's important kumail our
dear friend yeah there was a time when
let's just put like i got e-trade and it
helped the community can i phrase it
sort of vaguely like that one in what
way just like oh
[Music]
well not enough apparently he didn't
tell you no
but there was a time when we were
struggling artists for sure and if
somebody was like hey can you loan me
this or whatever
you'd go to the guy that just booked a
commercial and the guy would be like
this is the best like it was great and
and camille i i hope i'll i'll make sure
he doesn't mind me saying but like we
get emotional thinking about it yeah not
just that he received but that i was
able to give like i get emotional
because you had that opportunity and we
all we you were the epa you were the
cash cow i was the luna last
you were the luna lounge cash cow i
never did luna lounge really yeah oh
that might have been a little before
your day it was happening it was
probably a little bit tiny bit before i
wanted to do it
because now that i think about it i bet
camille didn't either because that would
have been just right before your time
well camille we used to joke but you
guys were i'm sure doing uh
uh uh invite them up
we did invite them up yes yeah and
eugene and i remember yeah that's
probably where i first saw you is you
did videos i'd never seen a comedy
community like rafi where you made a
video
parroting
eugene's videos oh yes yes and it was
you talking into a webcam yes and i
remember i got this really big laugh
that in the middle of it you took a huge
drink of whiskey and everyone laughed a
certain kind of laugh you only laugh
it's almost like a church laugh or a
summer camp laugh like he's making fun
of one of the counselors yeah you know
what i mean like she probably is
drinking while he's making those and i
was like
what is this every comedy club i had
been in was like
you know it was it was a different act
every weekend there was no community it
wasn't a place no it wasn't when i found
that place it wasn't the same scene so
we were a part of a scene yeah and then
that still carries over to me if i get
uh something that might not be cool but
it's for the money i'm bringing this
back to what you were saying
i still have this mentality let's still
do it let's still make it great let's
still make it great i love that but i'm
also like i should maybe i shouldn't do
this because i'm supposed to smoke
cigarettes with bobby in front of the
rafi and be a cool guy and at a certain
point i had to be like like
see to me then you get older and you
start wanting stuff like then you get
older and you start having kids i have
kids i have kids i need i want to be
able to afford for them to go to camp
well and like win them and take classes
and stuff came through i called mark
duplass
and i was like
look i love the script and i wanted to
do it but i literally didn't know how it
would look i was like is it too
mainstream like i was still going for
like i was going for zach yeah i did an
hbo show now i should do like an indie
movie or something this thing came
through i really liked it i'm so glad i
did it yeah but for a moment there east
village pops up and i called him and you
know what
said what do you say he go i said
literally i go what are people gonna
think when they see my billboard uh of
me and my family with a bowling ball and
he goes pete everyone's gonna think
pete's doing a show pete's got kids
that's that was like the first thing he
said was pete's got kids but like
there's a certain get over yourself sure
that's what flanny told me too he was
like stop being so precious well when i
moved to when i moved to l.a
um
i
i stayed in new york i feel like longer
than anybody although i feel like you
you stayed there for a pretty long time
too maybe i lived in 2010. okay so i was
so i was there until 2014. wow yeah and
i'm older than you yeah um you were back
then too i was i've always been older
dad jokes i've always been living you
always wanted um
i
uh
in 2014 you stayed long
i moved out here to be a mid-level
staff writer
on the
uh
uh rebel wilson sitcom
super fun night wait on warner brothers
yeah that's when i was doing my talk
show yeah i was on stage 10 and you guys
were on a different stage i didn't know
we were on the same stage at the same
time yeah
that's not mid-level
wait my my writing my if you were a
staff writer that's entry level if you
were a story editor on the staff yeah
but okay i really call
this just sounds like your agent didn't
tell you that you know
i was like i think i was like i think on
i think i was no we were credited as
like associate producers okay
but but um
but
i certainly wasn't i certainly wasn't
senior yeah i was in the middle okay
there were like mid-level yeah and
i was
you know showed up on the first day and
the other writers were like why are you
here really why are you here like what
what are you doing you're michael
shoulder why are you that's you're
really funny and i was like because i
need a job and you're like at least
you're better than tom green because i
need a job and i need a paycheck yeah
and and uh
like because
being recognized
in
in williamsburg
by cool people doesn't pay the bills
having really cool people in
williamsburg think i'm really cool is
great but it doesn't help me put my kids
in summer camp no unless you can pay for
their summer camp with with them
yeah
sorry you had one that was bad host bad
host let the guests do the riff
no no no no no no no no no i want you
dude i want you to do the riff yeah but
you had one
unless they pay and they go coach
michael coterone no i said cut summer
camp uh i said summer camp okay um
enid's enids enid summer camp no enids
would have been the bar where they were
buying me the cote d'irone
um
yeah
and uh i remember epstein-barr too
epstein and remember sugar
the late night yes diner yes ish it was
near sweet
i think oh yeah that might have been how
we met you would be co-hosting sweet or
whatever that was called sure yeah which
was a big deal to the people that were
in that show i believe it he's still
doing it to the people it's still
i went i actually went uh just a couple
weeks ago
he's in a new venue in chelsea and it
was packed really packed i believe it
joe derosa was performing and here's my
joe derosa asked me how the new star
wars was how's the new star wars it was
fine that's jodoro
i feel like if you knew him he had a
sandwich shop did you know that yeah i
did joey rose's heartache yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah um edit that out we don't want
to
no please no no
all plugs are you pay for your please
you pay for the party you pay for your
plugs um that's a bleep
that's hilarious i really really
appreciate that
when i was directing
wow
wow did you ever do it no you should
there's no editing
to me when i watch comedians in cars
getting coffee with jerry seinfeld
see what jerry said
the parts that i loved were when they
were ordering coffee so the part that i
love is when you know what i should do
for the inside just for your fans as an
inside joke like and then i actually did
it this time and then it's funny because
it's funny i mean
that would require effort it would
require effort we could do it
um i'm like katie you want to she's like
playing candy crush or something
actually katie's a great listener and
whenever i go like remember when we were
talking about this she goes i know where
that is and she'll
riffle something out really sometimes
you have to lift something out
interesting like that like the bong hit
thing that's gone i'm just kidding that
was one of my favorite moments did you
give her the signal like
yeah like like yeah
um can i go back to we're gonna get to
you as a director but this just came to
mind you as an actor okay i feel like
this i feel like this is a good question
oh yeah i'm excited i'm excited for you
to feel seen honestly like like i want
you to feel known and like huh i'm in a
i'm in a good little bubble okay
was there a time when you really wanted
to be an actor and wanted to be taken
seriously as an actor and the reason i'm
asking is because you remember the
sketch the blueberry guy yeah sure and
when i watch the blueberries
blueberry johnson
is pitching
a kids show and he looks like a
blueberry played by you yeah and the
executives are like we love it we just
don't want you you don't have enough
experience
you don't you don't have enough you
don't have anything
you don't have enough on-camera
experience
and he says
like i ha
he says basically like i majored in like
children's education in college
i am passionate about this i work really
hard and and to top it all off i look
like a [__] blueberry i look like a
[__] blueberry and then it ends where
he's in the control booth going cut to
camera one yeah push in and dissolve
yeah yeah so there was part of me that
when i i didn't even re-watch that
sketch that's just up there so funny
uh was there a time when you felt like
blueberry where you were like why is
everyone keep telling me to be behind
the camera no because no one was telling
me to be behind the camera either you
have an hour and a half right you got to
be out of here at 9 30. yeah okay
yeah that's what i was looking at yeah
yeah yeah
at uh show walter dead serious yeah i
think 11 30 right
uh
oh no 10 30 10 30 10 no 10th yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah sorry sorry
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i like did you draw that yeah
nice
no but did you draw that 60
that's cool
um
on your phone that's cool you're like
because you could have just like
you could have done it done it digitally
but you took the time to actually draw
it
if it didn't say sexy i would be like we
usually get a 90 light and this is when
i go start talking about god uh but uh
we're at 60 but we're do you ever get
the light and disregard it like do you
ever see the light and you're just like
[__] that yeah
how often do you stand up
i try to do it this is going to make you
laugh three four times a month
why is that going to make me laugh okay
i'm glad
well what would make me laugh about that
it's a lot
out loud no that was no that was me
going
wait a second pete my cup my i need to
set the record straight here
[Music]
i was finishing your sentence that that
they think it's not a lot that's what i
was saying when we were starting you had
to do it every night i have no opinion
of whether that's a lot or not a lot i'm
now realizing that it was silly to think
that you did i know
i really am i know why would mike i get
that there are some people like the
comedy seller crowd that just need to go
on stage every night the cellar boys
yeah or the z yeah that need to go on
stage every night well you you made a
whole television show about that that
time in my life was when i was going up
every night sometimes more than once a
night and are you doing new material
every night are you just not even doing
material are you literally just like
talking and i'm gonna bring it back to
you because i love this generous
question what i've been doing it for
over 20 years now so you can ve my val
watches me do stand up and she's like
when did you write this and that's my
favorite well you're very good at you're
a very good at you're sweet generous you
know what that means sweet generous
sweet i may not even myself know what
sweet generous means
but i think it means like
self-generating like
robin williams is the sort of
the sort of ultimate example of someone
who is three straight sweet gentlemen
who just starts talking and
20 minutes later he's still going and
it's all right hilarious gift of gab
you're a little bit like that what it is
is and this is i think applies to what
you do as well and i appreciate what you
said and i heard it and i accept it
i didn't want you to think i was doing
that thing where i can't take a
compliment okay well very good
i think you do that as well it's i just
want access to how i really feel yeah
and i think that's your job as an artist
is is we were looking at something and i
i thought it was the the poster was
overtly sexual but like kind of
unconsciously sexual i started
explaining to val why i thought the
poster was sort of subliminally sexual
and i was like you know i've noticed
something i'm not as afraid of my shadow
as i used to be like there might have
been a time where i was like it doesn't
because the poster i was like doesn't it
kind of look like they're an oral sex
position like doesn't it sort of look
like that and now i'm just like i think
they designed that to to look that way i
could be wrong but that's what it makes
me think of and i think i'm probably not
the only one i think that's our job as
artists is to like [__] get over it
like you think you're not enough you
think if people knew who you were they
wouldn't love you
you're afraid of death you're afraid of
rejection you're afraid of humiliation
like that's everybody and once you get
comfortable then you can generate that's
what robin williams was
he had been humbled by his sobriety by
all of these things and it was really
fun to watch him go
i can walk around the mansion in my
house all the doors are unlocked and
that's what makes somebody comfortable
improvising or generating wouldn't you
agree yeah absolutely i love that i
don't like the i don't like
i've i'd like not i don't like
i this is fun but generally speaking i
sort of don't want to hear my own voice
i know what you mean
but i re but but i mean that's not to
say other people shouldn't do it it's
great i love actors i love actors i
don't love acting in the way that i
think i once thought i would
because i don't
give a [__] about what i have to say as
an actor well also didn't you maybe if
you were like me not know that there
were other ways to create completely
like we kind of thought we had to be the
only thing i could it was the only thing
i knew that i had a shot at because you
you can't like you could go to college
and be in an improv group right or you
could go to college and be in a sketch
group you couldn't go to college and
like write a movie and it did this was
it seemed unattainable and sort of
like what's a joke you're a little
you're a little
half-grown man and you're like yeah i'm
gonna be the big shot it's like that's a
ridiculous prospect hundred percent but
if you could be the actor who knew but
you but you see that you see the improv
guys and you're like that's [__]
great that looks so fun yeah when i
watch old uh
state sketches and stuff and i watch you
and david specifically i'm like those
are guys that are going to be directors
like not
that sounds like a burn i i feel
there's more joy to be had
in other ways that sounds like i'm
saying
it comes off
no that's not what i'm saying i don't
think that's what you do but i watch
whatever i wouldn't mind absolutely not
um we both had unintentional everyone in
the state has directed
not mike black
mike black directed that out mike black
directed a feature
um mike black edited a feature starring
uh isla isla fisher and jason biggs
called wedding days was it good despite
the direction uh yes very much in
despite the direction or in spite of the
direction in spite of the direction you
know you're the last member of the state
to do the pod mike did it and i was
shocked i think
if you listen to it he's like at a time
in his life
maybe in between projects and i was just
talking about how great he was and he
was like i just don't know what you're
talking about like where's he on zoom
where is he with you it was on zoom he
was on zoom but it was really beautiful
yeah he's very self-difficult
very self-directed but his persona is so
like you're welcome yeah and then you
talk to him and he's like i don't know
if i'm ever gonna work again and i was
like it was beautiful he's a very sweet
man that's what i mean he's a very sweet
and lovely person i i completely agree
let's talk just because we are running
out of time um not really time
and i feel like you asked me a question
that we moved off of that was um do you
remember you asked me about blueberry
johnson and did you feel that oh did i
feel
and um
i wanted to be
i wanted to be a successful actor
because it's what i
felt like i wanted to be without having
the feelings that i now believe you need
to feel which is
like what i said which is like
you know
that i am my best self doing this yeah
and i never felt that way and never one
time felt that way um
so when i my big aha moment was when i
went and saw a play at the lincoln
center a check-off play not that that
matters but it was a check-off play and
i was joyfully watching it and it
occurred to me like i wonder if i should
be thinking
i wish i was in this show or i wish
that's so
like thinking about the acting and i
wasn't i was just enjoying it as an
audience member and somehow that really
struck me as like oh you're not an actor
i love you're not supposed to be an
actor like if other actors would be
watching this thinking about
themselves
you know in some way that's my one of my
old bits it's like an opener as i go
like is anyone here thinking like maybe
you'll get invited on stage because i've
never been to a play without thinking
like they're gonna pre pre-fame i mean
little boy like they're gonna ask me to
get on stage even a show that they don't
do that on that's what i mean like
there's lots of shows where they never
invited where where you watch the whole
show and they'll never invite you not
like it's a bit we're going in the
audience like the magicians always bring
always bring kids on
i always tried to do that and i got a
big laugh once they gave me rings oh so
you'd be like
and then and then try to get laughs i
did get laughs i correct you i did get
laps because he gave me two rings
and he said try and separate them
and i and he turned and he was talking
to them how old are you i'm like eight
and he comes back and he goes did you
separate them and i go i did but i put
them back together big laugh
funny
big laugh funny joke yeah this means a
lot that's a really funny joke for an
eight-year-old this means a lot to me
that's for an eight-year-old that's a
funny joke that was good that was good i
really did you
did you just is that just what came out
of your mouth or would you actually plan
it
i i think i thought of it a moment or
two before he he asked because that's
really funny i also thank you i deeply
appreciate that's genuinely funny
i love this moment
unexpected unexpected yes from a child
yes here's what i want to cover just
before we're out of here or anybody
really that's like a really funny you
know
like it's a zack joke yeah it's like a
zac sort of like i did but i put them
back together yeah like you like throw
away there was the um yeah go ahead
i just wanted to talk about sobriety i
remember the last time i saw you at
union hall
you uh punched me no i'm just kidding
but i i just remember
you seemed like i puked on you you did a
little what i've seen so what no i'm
saying now oh you you seem like you've
leveled the plane what happened at union
hall i just remember i think you had
just gone through a breakup or something
and it wasn't even alcohol or drug
related i just remember it was probably
very unhappy
i think i was yeah because i hadn't yeah
that was like i was yeah i was sort of
because i wasn't a comedian yeah i was
like what am i doing here we were
sitting by the bocce courts i i was yeah
starstruck and enjoying it very much
and what the reason i'm bringing that up
is not to embarrass you at all now i see
you and you have a light and i have to
assume that has to you figured some
things out including sobriety question
mark yeah sure sure i i i'm not um
absolutely i mean i
look i have been
i am very um
i i don't have a big philosophy about
this but it's not like i don't
i'm not
super
jonesing to talk about sobriety only
because i will a little bit only because
i don't feel
like qualified you don't want to be this
person yeah i understand but um
i
definitely
stopped a long time ago it's been almost
20 years
love it yep and i did want it now i'm
quite like i don't want to ask the wrong
question let's just say we can edit
anything out did you
decide i decided there was no rehab
there was no intervention yeah it was a
booze
boozy booze yeah boozy booze and but it
was it was really just but it was it was
a spiritual bottom more than anything
tell me yeah
it was just
oh god it's too much it's too much we
don't have time we don't have time
we don't have
in a way it's the um
a little bit for me it's that six
degrees of separation thing which is the
more i tell the story the less meaning
it has
i didn't know that's what six degrees
well that's what it means to me i loved
that i know that's what exactly
i i might i heard
and maybe i heard it wrong but the sort
of the idea of six degrees of separation
is like
every time a story gets retold or
something along these lines it's like
slightly less
so so it's like it's my story yeah it's
nothing mind-blowing i promise you that
yeah it's nothing
it's nothing earth shattering or
book-worthy or anything like that but
it's my story and in a sense the more
when i tell it it takes something away
but yeah you've given me a great gift
today yeah because i've actually had
some spiritual experience
sometimes psychedelic experiences i tell
the story
and i'm like i can feel it it gets one
click it starts becoming the story yes
instead of what it was exactly oh my god
so i'm so glad that that's that's what
you just said that's exactly what it is
because i can't i can't explain it to
you in a way that that will just that
will that will make it
that will make it
it's like i'm trying to convince you
i'll get into this thing where i'm like
trying to convince you of something
you're persuading me yeah and not
telling the story which if which as you
know is that you know the uh you know
you know
it was so bad i want you to feel
here's a battle i don't give a [__] how
about it well the beats well i remember
in church when people would share their
testimonies there were people that would
love it i used to hate it they'd tell
their stories and they'd be like it was
a rainy night and i'm just like yeah
[__] you it becomes a monologue yes like
an audition
when i was in uh high school it was a
very big honor to be are we done is it
time am i getting the hook um it was
just we do have this is fun you're good
i appreciate it you created a very nice
experience well it takes two it takes um
the uh
i was in something called peer group
which was
basically you you got chosen to be a
peer group leader and then you would
lead the freshmen in like
after school things you'd talk about
drugs and
sex and social adolescent stuff
and to be a peer group leader was a big
honor
and it really just meant you were
popular like at the time
i wanted it really badly because it was
like
it was a bit of a popularity contest who
got chosen to it was nothing to do with
that what actually wanting to help of
course kids that was the orientation
staff in college yeah
so
so um where'd you go to college
it doesn't matter it's boring i went to
christian college called gordon college
i don't know no one does okay not even
the people that go
[Music]
my daughter does that she's
she
you'll say something and then she'll
like be like
like you'll say a word or something and
then she's like disappointed like i
remember we recently someone said
disappointed and she's like disappointed
disappointed
i love that yeah she just repeats when
i'm in the most
like tuned in
like very present people will be like i
was aghast i'll just be like
because it's this reminder
for me
it's playful
you're creating reality that's what it
is and and you're ingesting and and
making what they're saying part of you i
i have this thing um and i catch myself
doing it all the time which is i repeat
everything twice yeah okay
so tommy two times tell me two times and
that's what i'm always going i'm like
i'm telling me two times i'll be like
um
someone will be say you know did that me
in directing situation you know was that
good was that was that did i do that the
right way i'm big it was perfect it was
perfect
i love it and i but i but i'm that's the
least example of it it would be like
anything by the way when i say something
i have an opinion
i repeat it yes um when i'm writing i
write like that and sometimes the
software will go do you want to re
remove this repeated well because it
kind of takes on new meaning every day
repetition is the best i love repertoire
it's i'm a big mammoth guy and they'll
put five [__] in there and a great
actress you play each [__] different
way and you're like oh my god it's like
i got the chills just think about it so
you were in high school you were one of
these cool popular people and there was
a day where like in the first meeting
you sort of tell your story or something
like i don't know like you have
in peer group you sort of do the session
amongst the seniors during the day and
then after school you have your freshmen
and then you lead them through the same
conversation so you know fifth period
was
peer group with an adult teacher and he
would lead us
and and there was
and everyone would go and it was like
you know oh my god so and so cried today
in peer group
and all of a sudden it's like you felt
pressure to come up with something where
you could cry you're bringing back a
feeling of a time
that is the feeling of adolescence it's
like okay for me yeah how do i cry how
do i cry like i need to tell a story
like i'm not cool now i'm not cool if i
don't tell a story about my something
that happened to me that gets me to like
that gets me to a cry place i am blown
away with how well you heard me when
sharing testimonies i didn't have a good
one mine was like i was born a christian
that was it
and this woman had like a conversion
story yeah i can't do it exactly i can't
compete exactly exactly um
100 like i'm i feel like i'm less of a
person because like i can't bring myself
i don't have the big thing
and why did i why was the point of
saying that i don't know we were talking
about something that connected sobriety
and the story and when you tell a story
too many times yes yes and then it and
then and then it's like i'm oh i told my
story and you're like okay that's a good
story and then suddenly i feel shitty
about my story and it's like i don't
need that melania has a bit about it
where he's like when you're dating you
tell the story you're like we were 13.
we were going through the reeds and we
found a body we didn't know what it was
at first and then when you're 30 you're
like i found a dead body
[Laughter]
you just get tired of telling the same
stories over and over yes you mean in
dating in dating like i have to tell
them right like your fifth grade you
have to
i stayed in relationships too long
because i was like i don't want to have
to do this again oh yeah i have my
brother he's older like yeah you should
just give them up like a you know like a
previously documented previously
here's my uh
here's all my stories here's all the
important information
i really think there's a sketchbook
previously on yeah yeah and you can skip
it yeah it's like
skip recap
but then you don't have to do it well
here's here's our way into the last
section uh and we'll do it briefly but
when i saw you i complimented you
specifically on tammy faye and and i
didn't know the oscars had happened and
um so did you not know that will smith
had slapped chris i did but i wasn't
watching them you didn't connect it and
you know what else was true is i did
check to see if jessica won and i was
very happy that she did before i saw you
or after i saw you it was before i saw
it was the day after the oscars but i
forgot
that's fine not to sound like a johnny
cool camel but i just don't care i don't
care about those things but you know
what's interesting like that she won you
know it's interesting well go ahead can
keep talking i'm not going to tell me
what's interesting
i no no i want you to continue well i
did compliment
only because we're running out of time i
did compliment how you framed religion
uh spirituality and i actually rewatched
it last night which was a pleasure and
that scene where she's going into the
church it's just so hard
the first scene the first scene but also
just throughout her faith being a blend
of
kitschy cookie but also ernest and
you're really threatening she really
believes she really has
she that's the that's the tragedy of
hers that she's a true believer i
believe that and i saw it and i saw
someone who was raised religious
whenever religion is portrayed it's
almost always like kathy bates believes
in jesus so she's gonna murder you or
whatever it's your insane zealous it's
it's zealotry it's zealotry or it's
crest white like mean girls they're like
i'll pray for you
and then they're like [__] [__] you
know like that that's the joke it's like
they're phony yeah or they're zealots
yes or there's you never see
michael we woke up i always say this but
we woke up in a conundrum you and i
became conscious in a very confusing
we're in outer space yeah we're in these
expiring meat suits you know what i'm
saying and
earnest
what is this
is is off the table because because
religion's been ruined by like
homelessness i don't like that at all
and xenophobia and all this stuff yeah
but like when you see a movie like you
made this is a good compliment i hope
you feel it
is like
some people actually all people are just
doing their best we're trying to figure
out some framework for the universe
and it doesn't mean i'm homophobic and
it doesn't mean i think you're going to
hell
it can mean i'm trying to
have a relationship with the mystery
100 and when i told you that i actually
was very delighted forgive my bias but i
do like when people like you were like
no i i'm i'm interested in that very
interesting tell me everything no and i
i mean i was raised the opposite i was
raised
very much in that mindset
of religious people or are uh you know
unenlightened
the irony of that opiate of the masses
yeah and that is the irony of that is
grace yeah because it's
yeah
you know that that
believing in god and all that stuff is
dogmatic and bogus and and and and all
of that and for probably for good reason
because they were
my parents were my mother's jewish my
father's an episcopalian that was their
you know they both they my mother was
you know
disowned for marrying my father so
there's a lot of like baggage around
sort of
the way in which
having been raised with
religion was
us something to shed a sort of a
a
sure it's not safe your mother
fell in love
and uh didn't convert but yeah but had
turned her back on her faith and now you
see
what those constraints can do yeah and
then it's really nothing to do with it's
really got nothing to do with spiritual
principles or anything like that it's
just like yeah right exactly and so
there was a kind of a healthy amount of
disdain i would say for for that or at
least that's what i perceive what a
trauma that's what i perceive
i had couples like that in our high
school
that the families didn't talk because
one was jewish and one was uh protestant
yeah and so that that i perceived that
and i didn't my myself didn't really
have an opinion other than that like as
a kid you're like do you believe in god
like no i don't believe in god you know
that was my whole thing was like i don't
believe in god um but i didn't really i
didn't really ever think about it or
anything and then
you know you go through life and you go
through life believing that you are the
center of the universe and this is
getting into sobriety stuff where
everything you do is something you did
and whatever you get from it is for you
and and and that you're not a part of
anything bigger than yourself you're not
interconnected you're just yourself and
it's you against the world and dead
which by the way is such a great way to
suffer yeah is to deny the
interconnectivity of all things and the
way to stop suffering is to recognize
that even if things aren't going your
way or whatever that you are part you're
interdependent yes things not going my
way my hurt heart might help me connect
to you and we both heal that's that's
joy and that it doesn't have to be tied
to a religious system 100 isolation is a
really good way to live and die all
these religions by yourself lots of good
things to say and lots of good ideas um
so
um
the spiritual bottom that i referenced
earlier in the in this pod in this
episode of your podcast
um
was one of i'm sick of being the center
of the universe i'm sick of the burden
of everything being about me
uh this is a good definition of
conversion by the way yeah i don't mean
to put words in your mouth i'm just
saying well i think i think that my i
think we and i think we talked about
this at all time we did yeah um edit
that out all the time
everyone knows i live near all time okay
but come say hi i don't want anyone
eating oh going to all times oh i'm
sorry we don't want to put that out
right that's
um i'm just trying to do your bit look
i'm just trying to jump i'm trying to
jump on your bit and you're like oh no
he's doing it wrong no no for a second i
thought you were just like people can't
know no people know where no i was
jumping on the bed um
his ego deflation was the big thing for
me which is literally like humility just
being like admitting that i'm not the
center of the universe that i'm not as
great as i think i am that that
everybody's
awesome everybody's fallible
it's not all about me blah blah blah
blah it's that this is it sing that that
is the sim single most been the single
most
mind-blowing concept to me
um and uh
and i really
do
god whatever
i
the
the sort of the spiritual
concepts um
around
the the the
sort of
the the greater purpose and and and the
kind of meaning of life let's say that
what's the meaning of life um is to live
and be a good person so what's what does
it mean to be a good person well you got
to go figure that out
um
that's all
that was the big aha moment for me and
the whole sort of like
god is stupid you're stupid
i have no time for that that's boring i
i can't be that person
so i'm very cynical i'm very
jaded in all these different
in all these different ways but
the eyes of tammy faye is a very sincere
story about someone who well the finale
utopian concept that god is love loves
everybody and that god is is loving and
that we could love each other and that
love has healing power and blah blah
blah and also symbols mean more to
people than individuals
she seemed to understand her i know you
can tease her persona but ask the gay
community what it meant to have a
christian woman oh my gosh
speaking for them richard rohr who's my
homeboy uh he's a franciscan friar and
some people are like why won't you leave
the priesthood you're so groovy he's so
outside the box and i'm like no
it matters to have someone who's in the
system
tell you yeah in the same way that it
matters that you're a comedian and you
say that was funny that was f you know
what i mean yeah we we're trans this is
young carl young we're transformed by
symbols not by
ideas or people it's like you want
batman you want tammy faye you want a
priest or a monk in a robe these things
matter and it's our subconscious
really yeah like pima
pima chodron
pima children yes yeah absolutely yeah
there you go she's a monk i just wanted
to say
one of the things you said
llama syria does who did this podcast he
always says rest your weary mind
and it's like that's peace
michael showalter recognizing that he
can't keep caring at all and acting like
he has it together that breaking that
change
is what i hear when jesus is saying
unless the grain of we die
and and crack
it won't grow into a plant so that was
your that was your sort of death and
resurrection if you'll allow that if
you're okay with that sort of absolutely
because the the young people that go i
got it pete matters it's about pete when
that dies for me it was my divorce has a
lot of these different humiliations well
there's the fear they took they talk
about it in in uh
you know in sobriety vocabulary they
talk about being the hole in the
doughnut have you heard of this no
um
the the fear is i don't even i never
really got it but i'll but i sort of get
it you know i do get it now the fear is
if i let go of this idea
that everything's about me
then i will be the hole in the donut
that's that's beautiful what
what will what will i be tomorrow
if i let go of the notion today
that everything isn't about me that's
why in not just
is i will be the hole in the donut that
will cease to exist
and and there is something so terrifying
about
letting go of that idea that
now i can't say for sure if i've like
succeeded at that but i can say
i can't even imagine the version of me
that couldn't let go of that and it took
me a really long time that's it and but
when you let go of it you go oh i'm
still alive i'm still walking around
like i'm i'm still a person i'm still
i'm still myself
well when you do the thing and i'm safe
thought you couldn't do when you do the
thing you thought you couldn't do and
you do it then you must not be what you
thought you were right right yeah so you
were afraid if you let go of that
illusion of control yes that you would
be the hole in the donut and then you
realize you're still here so you must
not be the thing that that couldn't do
and this still when you when you're
still when you have the i'm still here
moment that's the oh that's the biggest
thing it's oh that's the huge moment is
when you actually
get to the other side of the thing that
you didn't think you could get to the
other side of yes and you get to the
other side of it and you're like oh [__]
now
now i'm really starting to see things in
a different way that's right that's
confusing that's beautiful i don't mean
religious conversion i mean yeah
conversion 100 oh yeah oh in no
uncertain terms i i have been i love it
and i feel it i see it i just love it so
much yeah
if you're not who you thought you were
who are you and that's what we're here
to figure out and it's not michael
it's not michael from princeton new
jersey
who did this and this and this is it's
who you are in this moment how you
interpret reality
in this eternal present this is who you
are and it's what's looking out your
eyes so much more than it is your likes
and your dislikes and what you've done
and your accomplishments and whether or
not you were at the bar when will smith
slapped chris rock were you i wasn't at
the bar i was in my seat
you saw it i saw it can i ask you was it
i didn't even intend that was just a
comedy bit yeah it was really traumatic
for me it was horrible yeah it was
horrible like everyone was doing bits
like that night and i was like oh no i
hate it it was horrible it was one of
the worst
experiences i've ever had yeah right for
me too and i only saw it after it was
horrible i couldn't sleep that night i
um well
then jessica chastain won best actress
and it was like we had that then i was
really happy because you didn't want to
let
that moment r people say why was
everybody having fun and partying is
because everyone in that room had worked
for three years or more on whatever
movie they were there representing right
and didn't want to let that moment ruin
their night yeah you know we worked for
years on the eyes of tammy fan i wasn't
gonna like wallow in in in it but but it
was i didn't most of us most people
didn't realize that he had actually
made like slapped him i thought it was a
bit
where i where i
was what was traumatic was the second
part where he was screaming at him yeah
and that's where everyone's sunk in like
oh this is in a bit yeah and that's
where it got really really weird
but i still didn't even realize he had
actually slapped him until later wow
then i found there was a second level of
trauma which was then
uh acting like it didn't happen
yes i i really well you don't know what
to do you just don't know what to do i
can sympathize with that but they're
also like in any familial trauma
the the the thing that makes it hurt the
most is when the family pretends like
nothing happened yeah and i and that's
what i thought felt we were doing it oh
for
but i just needed to set the record
straight i was in my chair yeah it
wasn't at the bar you were not at the
bar i did spend some time down there but
um at the bar area or sort of like big
lobby area yeah um i have to imagine a
lot of people ran to the bar uh they
were doing weird notes well the show
just goes on forever you have to get up
and like
get some snacks yeah yeah yeah
yeah i love it so well i loved your god
answer i didn't mean to tarnish it with
you not in the least clickbait at least
we're not going to make click bait i'm
just saying like that's not the show
what a beautiful thing and really just
to practice what we we're talking about
it's like in this moment it's just nice
to see someone so spacious
and here and i'm happy for you
thanks pete you too and it's been really
fun i've loved it i was nervous you
weren't gonna do it because i still
think of you as east village mike that
won't do a dumb podcast
um but i'm so glad you did east village
mike um can i ask you one more please
can you think of a time in your life
when you laughed really really hard uh
to take the pressure out of it it
doesn't have to be a good story
just who are you with how old are you my
god maybe you were a kid these are the
prompts maybe someone you need to uh
you're bringing me to um
a fall no you're bringing me quickly to
i you said east village mike and so i
thought i was thinking about
uh
invite them up and that was eugene's
show and
and we went me and eugene and
uh
uh leo
um
toured with
leo allen toured once as we were called
we had with some ridiculous name that
eugene made up that of course i'm gonna
forget but it was like
the comedy men from outer space or
something like that he came up some
funny name for our tour and it was like
the comedy men from outer space
and um
we
got hooked on a song by
um
oh i'm gonna forget his name he's a
country singer but it was all about the
taliban
it was a song about the taliban
and it was so
and it was all about how we're gonna
kick the taliban and the butt and stuff
like that i think i remember that it was
some toby uh
toby keith okay toby keith
and
the three of us
passionately singing that song
in the car
along with the lyrics
and just thinking
just finding that road we got scene yes
the three of us
singing the lyrics to key toby keith's
taliban song at the top of our lungs
and just dying laughing because we knew
how silly it was
uh you said east village mike that's
what jumps you did it that's what jumped
to mind first of all one of the hardest
things to direct is to me recreate is in
a car because usually hot and it's a rig
and it's just not natural and those
moments so they're really unique they're
like little unicorns and when me and
chris thayer would travel around we were
singing the listerine song do you
remember it was a bottle of listerine
swinging on a vine and it would go
oh that was a song
and we must have been stressed out of
our [__] minds because we were
screaming it like
[Applause]
even louder than that in a little rental
car
driving through texas or wherever we
were
and we afterwards we talked about it we
were like that was primal scream therapy
like yes felt yes clear as a bell
and we were
oh my god that is so funny you really
brought me to that it's an incredible
memory yeah that's what that is primal
scream therapy car singing is primal
scream therapy i think yeah and valerie
told me that like your vagus nerve is
actually which regulates stress and
stuff is activated when you sing
so like singing we're supposed to sing
it like helps us and man and then he
would sing bob seeger and go she was a
little bit older and a lot less soul
than you used to be
and
we have video of me and i'm filming it
and i'm dying louder rock and roll
and i'm like
just
just doing it now felt good
it felt so good
so what again is the best yeah every
time he comes on that my dad goes his
father is a poet you know and i'm such a
little boy that wants him to see me and
i go your son's a comedian
i just always want to make him say that
no
but he loves bob seger and he loves but
i'm always like look at me daddy it's
actually quite sad
what a sad moment yeah he sees me i'm
just so needy like i'll never get enough
attention from my parents so i'm always
like but i'm special too right
um michael at least you know that that's
the main thing that's it i can go
through all the rooms yeah
that's the generator thing i love it
buddy thank you awesome all right
congrats on isaac tammy man uh anything
else you want to plug
uh i love that for you the new vanessa
bear show it's always showtime love that
title i love that for you and another
bear molly shannon
jennifer lewis vanessa bear matt rodgers
who famously only to me has ducked this
podcast two or three times
directed a few episodes and i'm very
excited about it very good so edit that
out edit that out
edit that out
i took away your bit because you uh what
you were about to do was about to be
funny because you were gonna go very
good and edit all that out but you did
it i didn't see how that was rejected
because i like it so much because
the last time you did it i didn't i
thought you were serious or something
it's a contagious bit it's a container
it's a bit that makes me want to do the
bit michael black used to do this thing
oh you should have asked him this darn
you maybe you could call up and do a
follow-up thing where he would you'd be
in an elevator
this is funny
okay
he would touch
them
on their clothes but they wouldn't know
it so he would touch them in a place
where they wouldn't feel it
so you won't feel that right
it's like a magic trick
so you'd be in the he'd be in the
elevator and the person in front of you
would have a bag on or something and he
would touch the bag
or or or have a coat and there'd be like
a little wrinkle in the coat and he
would just touch the wrinkle
need and i had to start doing that but
of course so it's the kind of big the
highest comment it was the kind of bit
that i just like you'd just be like that
bit looks so fun to do and so we would
it would be a race to see who could
touch
the thing and so it's like you know
you've got some like big strong guy in
front of you and he's wearing like a
house
a hoodie and you touched you just
touched the hoodie
until the reflective doors of the other
chatter did you touch mine and that's
happened it has this happened where you
get caught yeah to you it happened to me
once i touched the rim of a guy's cowboy
hat
and did he say
he was just like
it was scary like what are you doing and
i just was like acted like nothing
happened but it was this guy in a cowboy
hat and i touched that's one of my
favorite frequencies that human mammals
can do which is the agreed upon
let's just act like it didn't happen
like it's a thing we do we'll just
choose select all delete open apple a
delete
that's a 90 minute callback and i'm
proud of it open apple open apple d d
open apple d delete it i think so i'm
pretty open apple d
it depends on what program you're in but
yeah
we'll look into it thank you we have the
guests say keep it crispy okay this is
crispy you didn't even need it
keep it crispy
[Music]
you may be